يفترض ان طرفي الصراع وافق على تمديد
الهدنه من الرابع الى الحادي عشر من مايو
الجاري ليس هكذا تكون الاستجابه لمقترح
ايجاد
بين القول والفعل منذ السبت الذي سيذكره
السودانيون بمراره وحده هذا المشهد الذي
لا يتغير فهل سيغير بيان اخر للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن شيئا ام سيلقى نفس مصير
البيانات السابقه الداعيه الى وقف
الاقتتال والعوده الى ما قبل الخامس عشر
من ابريل الماضي بينوا هذه المره يمهد
لخطوه قد لا تتاخر اذ اعلن امرا تنفيذيا
جديدا يسمح بفرض عقوبات تحمل الافراد
المسؤوليه عن تهديد السلام والامن
والاستقرار في السودان وقال ان العنف
الدائره هناك ماساه وخيانه للمطالب
الواضحه للشعب السوداني بحكومه مدنيه
وانتقال الى الديمقراطيه اشار الى ان
الحكومه الامريكيه مستعده لدعم الجهود
الانسانيه المختلفه في السودان عندما تسمح
الاوضاع الميدانيه بتقديم المساعدات نجحت
فيه الولايات المتحده وغيرها من الدول
والمن الدوليه والاقليميه منذ بدايه
الازمه هو اشلاء الرعايه من هناك حديث
الضغوط من اجل وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
والوساطات لانهاء التناحر والفوضى التي
تتمدد وتتوسع تبدو بلا امل في حدوث اختراق
وشيك كان الجميع استسلم لسيناريو الاسوا
قالتها صراحه مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه
الامريكيه الصراع قد يطول
انسودان
تقديرنا ان القتال في السودان بين القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع من
المحتمل ان يستمر لان كلا الجانبين
يعتقدان ان بامكانهم الانتصار عسكريا وان
لديهما القليل من الحوافز للجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات يسعى كلا الجانبين الى
مصادر خارجيه للدعم وهذا الامر في حال نجح
فمن المرجح ان يزيد من حده الصراع ويخلق
احت اكبر لانتشار التحديات في المنطقه
قبلها بيوم سمع ايضا اعتراف للامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش يزيد من
قسمه الصوره الجاليه للحاله السودانيه
تحدث عن الاخفاق في منع اندلاع الحرب التي
فاجات الامم المتحده على حد قوله في
القاهره اوضح مبعوث الجنرال البرهان ان
الجيش قبل بمبادره الهدنه السعوديه
الامريكيه وليس وساطه لحل النزاع لا يعرف
هل سينتهي على بدء الاجتماع الطارئ لوزراء
الخارجيه العرب الاحد المقبل في العاصمه
المصريه لبحث ملف السودان الساخن جدا
لدرجه ان نيرانهم قد تحرق دول المنطقه اي
افاق للجهود الدبلوماسيه العقيمه حتى الان
هذا هو الافق الوحيد المؤكد منذ 20 يوما
مع كل دقيقه اضافيه من الحرب يموت اناس او
يرمون في الش وارع ويزداد تفكك الدوله
الكلام لوزير سوداني مدنيا سابق